antes de que teherán despierte estos
hombres se preparan para la jornada que
les espera
todos son llegados de otras provincias
de irán de donde tuvieron que emigrar
debido a la falta de empleo que se ha
hecho mayor durante la pandemia este es
el caso de yúnes que vive en una
habitación del bazar para poder enviar
el dinero restante a su familia consumar
las ventas se han caído y no es posible
que suban nuestros sueldos son los
mismos
la crisis económica que se hizo peor
desde la imposición de sanciones en 2018
ha tenido un gran impacto en la
población que se siente abandonada por
el gobierno algunas encuestas arrojan
que la participación en las elecciones
presidenciales del 18 de junio no
superaría el 40 por ciento con cada
presidente que llega siempre pasa lo
mismo hablan dicen entender todos
nuestros problemas prometen pero luego
no hay diferencia para nosotros la
incapacidad de los políticos para
adaptarse a las necesidades de los
iraníes contrasta con una gran parte de
la sociedad que empuja por mayores
aperturas a una de las dificultades al
comienzo era que no pensaban que una
mujer pudiera hacer este trabajo creían
que era imposible
actualmente marian tiene a su cargo más
de 25 hombres algo impensable hace unos
años para una mujer tradicional que
creció en una familia campesina en el
este de irán ahora los clientes están
cómodos porque dicen que las mujeres son
más dedicadas perfeccionistas y conocen
más los detalles el cambio social ha
llevado a empresarios a apostar por
negocios que no encajan en el modelo de
país que defiende el sector más
conservador y religión
pasaron desde el momento que decidí
quedarme en el país invertir dinero y me
convertí en hombre de negocios acepte
también que tenía que afrontar algunos
problemas como existen en otras partes
las demandas de los iraníes y las
soluciones que ofrecen los gobernantes
son cada vez más lejanas como quedará
demostrado una vez más en esta campaña
electoral que estará dominada por
candidatos conservadores